[Musique]
c'est sûr que moi la danse je suis fait
pour ça je me sens bien dans un théâtre
je me sens bien dans mon studio morgan
le tchèque adam c'est presque toute sa
vie depuis qu'elle a enfilé sa première
paire de chaussons à l'âge de 5 ans elle
n'a jamais cessé de perfectionner son
art la fermeture des salles de
spectacles a tout changé
c'est sûr qu'il ya eu un gros choc
émotionnel je pense qu'on est passés par
des hauts et des bas avec des moments de
qu'est-ce que je fais j'arrête tout ça
va durer combien de temps qui ont santé
un petit peu inutile soudainement un peu
rejetés
le choc est survenu après une brillante
carrière
morgan a fait ses premiers pas avec la
la la human steps pour ensuite se
joindre aux ballets jazz de montréal
à la compagnie marie chouinard et au
cirque du soleil
à 34 ans l'heure est à l'introspection
c'est vrai que pendant cette pandémie
j'ai beaucoup repensé à toutes mes
tournées je veux dire ah c'est vrai je
suis allé là je suis allé là même si là
ça s'est arrêté pour moi je pense que je
n'ai pas tant un deuil
enfin j'ai enfin j'ai comme un petit
deuil à faire mais c'est pas un deuil
qui est triste et 2 et on nouveau
éloigné de la scène à cause de la
pandémie
la danseuse interprète si oui à
l'enseignement secondes et jo elle à
continuer de rêver et d'être en
mouvement
utilisez les deux bras je reviens j'ai
créé un film de danse cet été c'était
vraiment une nouvelle expérience qui m'a
apporté beaucoup d'autres choses une
nouvelle perspective sur le corps sur
l'image
c'était hyper intéressant quand même
pour moi puis ça me permettait de
continuer dans ses pieds de rester
vivant en plus de danser et l'a senti le
besoin de communiquer et de créer un
balado on se voyait plus entre danseurs
donc c'était le médium idéal de balados
même si j'ai aucune expérience en
journalisme aussi juste lancé comme ça
qui essayait de me renouveler aussi
moi-même finalement
mais sa plus grande décision son plus
grand projet n'est pas encore né
[Musique]
dans son ventre
un enfant conçu en raison de la pandémie
donc il ya toujours ce dilemme de quand
est-ce qu'on fait un enfant c'est
tellement important notre carrière on
est tellement passionné que souvent ça
passe avant qu'il a vraiment la pandémie
est arrivé et je pense que c'est sûr que
pour moi ça a énormément fiancée la
prise de décision la maternité est un
sujet presque tabou dans le milieu de la
danse mais peut-être que le temps
d'arrêt pousse à la réflexion
un baby boom au niveau de la danse dont
je suis très très heureuse de sa la
pandémie ça aura permis de s'ouvrir à ce
sujet
en attendant la naissance prévue en juin
est impatiente d'assister à la fin de la
pandémie
morgan a imaginé cette chorégraphie sous
le thème du bre temps et de jours
meilleurs à venir
imaginons un jugement comme une vague ou
de loki qui fait cool donc pour moi
c'était c'est presque en main on
préparation à cette naissance
[Musique]
la musique qui accompagne saturé graphie
est interprété par le futur papa
un musicien aussi touché par le
confinement nous ça nous est clairement
inspiré à avoir un enfant et on est sans
le citer tous à converger vers ce la
pandémie aussi le fait que on arrive à
un moment notre carrière ou sa cité ça
ça revient pas mal ça s'approche de la
dernière chance
côté artistes faut que je regarde aussi
parce que j'ai assez de stabilité dans
ma carrière que je sais que je peux
quand même me permettre ce est-ce que
j'ai assez de revenus
la pandémie nous aura fait vivre le
meilleur et le pire
pour morgane lethiec rien ne sera plus
comme avant
si je dois faire un deuil des tournées
je ferai mon deuil puis je dirais
peut-être plus vers l'enseignement
après aussi dans ma tête l'idée de
changement complet de carrière ça c'est
aussi une option qui est très présent
d'ailleurs en ce moment dans le milieu
de la danse
je me laisse quand même flotter parce
qu'on sait pas ce qui va se passer
[Musique]
il nous avons le privilège de les avoir
avec nous voici morgan lethiec et
pierre-alexandre
[Musique]
printemps sort de terre
étrange
dans la glaise
[Musique]
lève ses regards
vers l'est de l'état
[Musique]
et le sang
du soleil couleur du ciel
[Musique]
je veux seul
sur l'a6
oedème
le vent basané
beck 7 e nos poumons
je vais
[Musique]
c'est zéro
les nuages qui passent
[Musique]
coeur qui trop souvent
grandes comme la main
est rempli
zéro
de ceuta salines
ce soit nar
2 tu
rien de noix
rien dames 1
[Musique]
ce qui
sauf
auchan
mais voilà
là
k
un petit de l'oise
voulez vous
je
[Musique]
tout mon corps
je